♪ (music) ♪
Hi, everybody, and welcome
to TensorFlow Meets.
It's my honor to be chatting
with Karmel Allison, Engineering Manager
on TensorFlow today.
Now, Karmel, you do all
of this outreach stuff,
as well as engineering management.
You had these video series on YouTube,
you've done talks at conferences,
and I know you did a great talk
at the TensorFlow Developer Summit.
Can you tell us a little bit
about you, what you do,
as well as all this great stuff.
Yes, so as you mentioned,
I'm an Engineering Manager for TensorFlow.
My team works on high-level APIs,
so that's Estimator and Keras.
And my talk at the Dev Summit this year
was about what we're bringing in 2.0
for high-level APIs,
and, specifically, about Keras,
and how that's the primary high-level API
that we're consolidating
a lot of the things we have under,
and bringing the scale
of Estimator into Keras,
and how we're going
to be doing that in 2.0.
That's really interesting-- bringing
the scale of Estimator into Keras.
I know there's going to be
tons of questions about that.
One of the things
I thought was really interesting,
was that you had this slide
where there was
this "spot the difference."
You had like training a DNN,
I think it was in Fashion-MNIST in 1.13,
and then, in 2.0, and there was
no difference between them.
So, what's the real message behind that?
Yes, so François Chollet,
the creator of Keras,
is really, really one of the champions
of the user experience,
and he's done a great job of that
with the Keras API thus far,
and we wanted to be able to keep that--
minimize, first of all, the overhead
in having to convert for people
who're already using Keras,
but also just to retain that simple API
as we move into 2.0.
At the same time,
we were able to bring everything
we're bringing to the table in 2.0,
into that same model in Keras.
So, that same model works
in Eager Mode and in Graph Mode,
so the same one in 1.13
would be Graph Mode,
but in 2.0, it's going to be
in Eager Mode,
which allows you to more easily debug,
prototype, and all of that.
It also works
with Distribution Strategies,
with Feature Columns.
There's all these different tools
and pieces that we're bringing in 2.0,
we wanted to make sure
that same Keras API worked,
as it does now.
I see, okay, cool.
Now, you've mentioned
Distribution Strategy.
So one of the things,
it's not just making it easier
for the coding part of the cycle,
but the training part of the cycle
and being able to go big.
So could you tell us a little bit
about what Distribution Strategy
is all about and how it works?
Yes, so Distribution Strategies
is a set of strategies,
a set of ways to distribute your model.
There are a number of them,
including MirroredStrategy,
which is distribution across multiple GPUs
on the same device or on the same machine.
There is also
MultiWorkerMirroredStrategy
where you're mirroring
across multiple machines,
all with their own devices.
And we've also got coming
in the future ParameterServerStrategy
which is going
to be distributing asynchronously
across hundreds of nodes,
which is the kind of training
we also do at Google.
It's really exciting to build that in
as a simple API, a flexible API
that works for DeepMind,
for Google researchers,
but also for the people who are outside
of the TensorFlow repository right now.
To make it easy to use,
but also really performant.
There's a lot of work
that's gone in under the hood
to make sure
that the scaling efficiency is really high
even though the code stays simple.
Nice, nice.
And now this becomes available
- to almost anybody who wants to use it.
- Yes, we hope.
You don't have to be a Googler.
So now, I'm going to put you
on the spot for a minute,
because this all great new stuff
that we've been talking about
in TensorFlow 2.0--
do you have a favorite?
I think some of the things
I'm most excited about are tf.functions.
So, this is some of the magic
we're bringing in in Eager Execution,
where you can actually
continue to use graph style code
and get the performance
of graph style code,
even though you are in Eager Execution.
That's one thing.
Another is what I just mentioned
which is ParameterServerStrategy.
That's the way that we're
going to be able to distribute
some of the largest workloads
we have at Google, using Keras models.
And I know that there are a lot
of researchers, internal to Google
and externally, at some
of the largest companies we work with.
We're excited to be able to take
the same model they prototype
and take it all the way
to production, training, and serving,
using Distribution Strategies.
That's something
I'm really excited about.
Nice. It's hard to pick
just one favorite, right?
- Thank you so much, Karmel!
- Thank you!
This has been,
as always, very informative,
and if you've got any questions for me,
or if you've any questions for Karmel,
please, just leave them
in the Comments below.
And whatever you do, don't forget
to hit that Subscribe button,
so you'll be able to see
the rest of Karmel's videos
right here, on YouTube.
Thank you.
♪ (music) ♪